and this is the concept car behind you
tell us about it good morning rich from
Singapore yeah this is our concept car
as we strongly believe that the future
will be electrified autonomous and as
you mentioned that cars will become
mobile devices you can see many features
in that car already
right so concept cars rarely make it
into production but elements of them of
course do what are the elements do you
think from this concept vehicle which
you think will become mainstream in a
few years and become standard on a BMW
I think you can see probably most of the
elements in that car in the future
production so this car can drive fully
autonomous which will have we will have
available probably a beginning of the
next decade and other things like the
connectivity that the car will give you
some information about the driving in
the morning and so on you will see very
soon in our cars right what you know
what about your competitors in this
market everybody's starting to get into
this autonomous vehicle space do you
think it's perhaps getting a bit too
crowded
it's like always you have the trends and
we clearly want to lead the trend and we
are putting a lot of effort to make it
happen a lot of questions need to be
answered to make it really happen but
we're also working with the state of
Singapore and the University here
together because Singapore might be one
of the ideal places to test it out for
mega cities in the future all right
what's what's the business strategy he's
saying that will get autonomous cars
perhaps at the beginning of the next
decade as we go towards there I guess
we'll have incremental autonomy in
vehicles or cars become have incremental
changes such as that but tell us what
what's your vision like for the next
three to five years then
I mean a lot of the connectivity
connectivity will go into the cars and
also better battery technology will
improve massively so you have seen our I
Sri and I ate so we have introduced the
I Brent in 2013 and this technology is
not going more and more into our core
brains where you can see the hybrid
technology moving into our core brand
which is then called I performance okay
well let's talk a little bit about the
market at the moment and how you're
doing which I mean you essentially
manage Southeast Asia here and a not
China but which is your strongest market
that you look after currently and which
is the one which you find a few
headwinds
I mean actually this part of the world
is actually still the fastest growing
and we predict that the growth will
continue so a lot of opportunities for
for business to make here and but if if
you want me to pick some markets in the
region
I would probably at the moment pick
Vietnam we see very strong goes over the
last three years in Vietnam and it seems
to be continued that way but we are also
exploring new markets so our latest
market we entered was Myanmar end of
2014 and we already expanded into the
second city like Mandalay and this is
probably not the volume market for the
next five or ten years but we want to
enter those markets early and
established our brand there right what
about what about Hong Kong what about
the Philippines and indeed other places
here you know where are you getting the
headwinds
I mean these countries generally suffer
from a lot of political changes in a
very short time so we we see a
fluctuation fluctuating development of
those markets but you mentioned
Philippines Philippines also since a
couple of years from gross part and
that's the same development you can see
there as well but we know that this
region will have some up and downs we
have seen that in the past but we will
go through there now what about China I
know you don't look after China but I'm
sure your conversations with your
colleague there what are you making of
what's happening how is the slowdown
they're impacting your bottom line
I mean China last year saw a dip and I
think we in China we call it now the new
normal but we are still growing in China
so it's not the double-digit growth
anymore but the single-digit and when
you talk about the ASEAN markets for
example yes they are depending on China
but the overall trade is like 15 percent
with China so they are not too much
depending on China as I have a lot of
trade relationships to the other parts
of the world as well axle very quickly
here what about cultural differences
European customer versus a customer in
this part of the world are there
differences in what they like in their
vehicles compared to what's happening in
Europe or the US perhaps
yeah partly I mean what you wait the
experience quite often in in Asia that
you have drivers so their focus more on
the rear seat so we also focus on the
entertainment system and and we also see
the trend that more and more people are
moving into the cities so therefore you
spent more and more time in the car and
therefore we we really concentrate on on
the connectivity of the car and make the
car your office and your entertainment